oh they were explosive and the numbers
for desean watson were very impressive
with relatively limited throws he only
threw the ball 20 times but he completed
16 of them that's 80
239 yards that's an average of nearly 12
yards per attempt and five touchdown
passes now
more than half of the yards came on two
of the touchdown passes but still it all
goes into the same bucket and it was
explosive and you throw in a running
game where lamar miller against his
former team the dolphins averaged 7.4
yards per attempt and had well over 100
yards this is an offense that had its
way with the miami dolphins defense and
it was it was so bad that adam gase i
watched his full press conference this
morning before the show i mean he seemed
a little shell shocked by what happened
and and
he kind of left the door open to make a
change at defensive coordinator moving
on from from matt burke it it did it did
seem like that could happen
he he said he hadn't thought about it he
doesn't see it happening that that's not
the strongest endorsement of continuing
with the guy that that uh is presiding
over a defense that is getting gashed on
the ground and got shredded in the air
even on only 20 throws last night by
desean watson but uh and then this this
fact and this is
this is an example of how we get caught
up in what's happening now
because patrick mahomes has become that
bright new thing in the nfl that we all
get excited about last year it was
desean watson
early november tears in acl and we move
on that's the one thing about the nfl
somebody gets injured the game moves on
you just you just what are you going to
do you're going to stop the season
because a guy who was on track to be mvp
got injured no you keep going and we
forgot about deshaun watson and then the
season for him started slowly at a time
when it was starting the exact opposite
of slowly for patrick mahomes so mahomes
became the bright shiny new object in
the nfl
and we shouldn't have forgotten about
desean watson because he is now
after
kind of working his way into things
eight games in he's looking a lot like
the guy he was last year still have
concerns about his physical style of
play he's playing with a broken rib and
there was a partially collapsed lung and
he had to travel to jacksonville by bus
and there's a chance he's got to travel
to denver by bus next weekend for their
game against the broncos there
but desean watson looking every bit the
guy that he was last year and
and
34 touchdown passes in 15 games
that passes dan marino for second most
touchdown passes in a player's first 15
games and i know that that these
statistical achievements can get very
very specific but still
they're not going to put a plaque you're
not going to get even a laminated piece
of paper for this but
15 games 34 touchdowns second most
touchdown passes of all time
in front of dan marino
along the way deshaun watson has missed
plenty of games but uh still very
impressive and uh now that the texans
are five and three and now that everyone
is going to be jumping on the bandwagon
coach bill o'brien tried to slow things
down a little bit when he spoke to
reporters after the game
i know it's five in a row it's it's
really good like i'm not trying to
downplay that but
it's five and it's only eight games in
nothing's been determined you know
so what have you done
yeah what have you done is you've won
your last five games in a row but it all
can turn very quickly they could go to
denver and lose they could lose coming
out of their bye week and you know we we
do have a very short memory
as we study this game and if you're on a
winning streak you're great and if
you're on a losing streak you stink and
there isn't much in between and it's all
be i think because
there are so few games relative to other
sports each game means so much that how
you play in one given week is going to
influence dramatically how you are
perceived and if you have a game that
seems to be out of character that that
stink is still going to be there until
you get a chance to prove that that game
was the aberration that's just the way
it is when there are only 16 games per
year statue got a question going into
the season i felt like houston was the
afc media darling that everybody liked
and thought could challenge the patriots
given how they've played are you now
willing to say that they are the team
that we thought they were going to be
starting the year
i don't know that everybody thought they
were the team that could challenge the
patriots i i thought that there was kind
of an open question there hinging on
players staying healthy i mean my view
on the texans worry if they can keep
their core players healthy they can win
the division and be a factor in january
i don't think anybody was penciling them
in as a team that could knock off the
new england patriots especially because
they seem to struggle every time they
play the patriots but i remember when we
picked our our division winners back in
late august early september you know the
easy play was jacksonville and i went
with the texans because i thought they
could hold it together long enough to
win the division and that doesn't mean i
think they're going to be able to win in
the postseason i i hope that we see a
desean watson patrick mahomes match up
at some point in january i'm not quite
sure which guy i'd root harder for
because i like both of them a lot but i
i think that that they are
are working their way to get to the team
that they could be but they're only one
game away from losing a cornerstone
player that's going to make everyone
view them differently and i think that's
been the book on the texans over the
past several years they can't keep all
their key players healthy if they ever
could keep all their key players healthy
for the balance of a season then they
could be a potentially dominant team but
we just assume that given the wear and
tear given the grind given the
physicality of the sports somebody at
some point who is one of the core
players on the texans is going to get
injured and it's going to be a factor
i've mentioned this to sean watson
patrick mahomes dynamic
for uh uh
throughout the show really and we
tripped over this and it's become the
question that we put out on twitter that
we're going to
take your input on and and see how the
poll works out i think i know how it's
going to go i think because i think we
do get too caught up in new but between
patrick holmes and deshaun watson which
guy do you want for the next five years
and i don't think it's as an easier
question as you think because when stats
posed it to me stats i don't even think
i took a nanosecond break i just blurted
out patrick holmes i didn't even i
didn't even say this a tough question
patrick holmes i couldn't believe how
quickly you decided
yeah but you know what now that i've
thought about it a little bit more
mm-hmm
yeah i mean maybe look we haven't seen
we've seen the peaks for patrick mahomes
we haven't seen the valleys yet
and
there are now seven games of film that
are out there for
any defensive coordinator to study
and maybe at some point they throw some
hurdles out in front of mahomes that he
can't handle i think he'll be fine i
love the way he improvises in a very
controlled way he you know every once in
a while we see somebody who just
who tries too hard and goes beyond their
physical abilities that's one of my
criticisms of jameis winston he's good
for one of those plays it seems like
once every month or two you'll see this
ungainly awkward jameis winston play
because his brain is telling his body to
do something his body can't do mahomes
has a very strong sense of athletic
self-awareness if that's even a term the
idea that he knows what he can do he
knows what he can't do and he's always
able to color within the lines no matter
what's going on around him and he knows
what throw he can make he knows if he
can make a throw with his left hand if
he needs to he knows when to put touch
he knows when to zip it he knows where
he can put the ball when he's out of the
pocket he throws so much more
effectively out of the pocket because of
that and i think he always stays within
the limits of his god-given abilities
now it helps to have a very high level
of god-given abilities i mean i'm
staying within the limits of my physical
abilities by sitting here right
so well done
the more you can do
the harder it is to know where the line
is but it's also harder to get to the
line the more you can do so check out
the poll that we have on twitter and
we'll we'll provide some updates
throughout the course of the show and if
any of you have some colorful and
non-profane responses maybe we will
share them with the crowd adam gase had
some non-profane responses when he spoke
to reporters but he was clearly not
pleased here's a little taste of where
the dolphins third year head coach
currently is
fairly irritated right now so
i'm going to reevaluate everything this
weekend i mean we got the extended
weekend we got to figure out how to get
better on defense
we got to figure out how to sustain
drives and put it in the end zone on
offense
yeah and look it's not going to be easy
because there were a lot of injuries
especially on the offensive side of the
ball receivers injured and devonte
parker stepped up if they're showcasing
him they did it well six catches for 134
yards for devante parker last night the
problem is if you trade him who's
playing receiver for the miami dolphins
there was a thought that they were going
to move on from him because they're
getting to the point where they have to
make some big decisions financially and
maybe one way you avoid those decisions
is to just trade the guy like they did
with jarvis landry when they were
looking at the franchise tag for him so
the dolphins have lost their way after
starting 3-0 the adversity from last
year has returned this year it feels
more self-inflicted although injuries
aren't really self-inflicted but last
year it was a bunch of external things
that conspired against the dolphins this
year it's just the dolphins
not being able to be consistent not
sustaining the things they did earlier
in the year and not having ryan
tannehill as a factor i mean
it was fun when brock osweiler beat the
bears but now he's lost two in a row and
he's lost two in in five days that's the
thing about that short week man that
that short week is like an all-in bet in
poker like because you got five days
and there's a chance your team's going
to be dramatically better or
dramatically worse in the course of five
days look at the dolphins they were
four and two
on sunday morning four and two
and now they're four and four
and
the texans were three and three and now
they're five and three five days later
your fortunes can change quickly when
you look at that sunday to thursday you
look at those two games together and we
saw it work out well for the texans and
it hasn't worked out well for the miami
dolphins and the dolphins go into their
mini buy and we'll figure out if they do
anything to make some changes coaching
staff wise as i said earlier adam gase
didn't exactly slam the door on changing
defensive coordinators but you know
that's just reeks of desperation and
it's just an effort to try to turn
things around on the fly and i don't
think it ever works very well how many
times you know there's nothing standing
out for me stats where someone has fired
offensive coordinator in season well i
have one example i have one example
other than the one example i'm thinking
of mid-season changes to coordinators on
either side of the ball typically does
not
result in a dramatically good outcome
although there is one example i can
think of and it's probably something you
should be remembering in a very negative
way yes i remember that would be the
baltimore ravens when they won the super
bowl is that what you're referring to
that was december of that year cam
cameron got the
thanks for not thanks for nutting see
you later and uh jim caldwell took over
and propelled the ravens offense to the
super bowl that year where they beat
your san francisco 49ers hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching make sure
to hit subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports